good morning everyone i'm very
uh delighted to have the opportunity to
share with you guys
uh the advancing reproductive health
through innovative genetic analysis
solutions
here at thermo fisher scientific my name
is george he
as tamra had introduced i'm the director
for global market development and
marketing
for reproductive health
at reproductive health we want to be
your trusted partner
through three pillars first as you see
on the left
is by offering innovative genetic
solutions
that enables customers like you to make
future generations healthier
second we want to advance your business
growth with a comprehensive menu of
reproductive
health solution and finally by providing
reproductive health customers like you
with our world-class
support to make sure that you are
successful in serving your customers
let's dive deeper into our comprehensive
menu solution
as we discussed just now as you can see
here
it's a circle of reproductive life
cycles
and we have comprehensive solutions from
expanded care screening
or care screening at 11 o'clock to
pre-implantation genetic testings
both for aneuploidy and monogenic
disorders
at one o'clock to prenatal testing
at four o'clock newborn screening at six
o'clock
and finally at postnatal testing at
eight o'clock
we see this as a continuous circle
because
any part of the information that you
have gathered through this life cycles
can provide meaningful information to
decide
on future pregnancies
you can learn more at thermofisher.com
rh let's
go straight into care screening
care screening by default is testing for
autosomal recessive disorders
and these are typically inherited
disorders and rare
by definition what is a rare disease
means a rare disease defined by nih is a
condition that affects
less than 200 000 people globally
but collectively they actually have over
7000
of these rare diseases so it's actually
not that rare
collectively and as a group because of
these numbers
there are actually one in 10 individuals
in the u.s
that are affected with an inherited
disorders
and these rare diseases are now a burden
because
over 35 of the mortality
happens before one year of age are
caused by these rare diseases
and over 18 percent of the pediatric
hospitalizations
are also caused by these rare diseases
so how are these rare diseases detected
previously these rare diseases
and variants are bucketed into two
buckets
on the left sequence variance and on the
right
structural variants sequence variants
are what you can think of as single
polymorphism detection or
multi-nucleotide variations
and some of the disease examples are
like beta thalassemia
or sickle cell disease and cystic
fibrosis
typically sequence variants are detected
using sanger sequencing
mainly used for confirmation they use
genotyping
or next generation sequencing
on the right structural variations are
what we typically call
copy number variations or deletions
duplications
some of the disease examples are
duchennes and
backer muscular dystrophy and alpha
thalassemia
how has been detected up to this point
are mostly through
mlpa or real-time pcr so what you can
see
here is that different types of variants
actually are being detected
using different types of technology
which is difficult
comes in and time consuming
so what do we do what do we offer here
at thermo fisher
to solve those challenges we actually
have two major buckets here
as you can see either care scan which is
a flexible
scalable high throughput care screening
solution
or the ones on the right which is
keroseq are rigorously designed for
expanded care screening research
both addresses two very critical ps
which is consolidations of standalone
essays to improve
lab efficiency and it has comprehensive
coverage
from the content source that you trust
and their pan-ethnic content
the major differences are the ones on
the left carrot scan
it's a microarray solution with a very
robust
software solution whereas keroseq on the
right
is an ngs solution so you actually got
options to find the right tools for your
lab's purpose
so let's dive a little deeper into care
scan essay here
this is a 6000 mana curated
relevant variant design on the array
that covers 600
inherited disorders and our pan-ethnic
content they are designed through acog
and acmg database
so it's very reliable it's something
that everybody trusts
it includes multi-allylic and biolic
snip
indel and cmv it avoids neighboring
variants and snips
and minimizing interference from
pseudogenes
it's now tested actually over a thousand
variants
through verified true positive samples
here
let's dive a little deeper here besides
those
what i mentioned just now i want to
drive your attention to the
honeycombs here on smn1 hbb dell dupe
dmd dell dude and hba 1 and 2
dell du these are all typically harder
to detect genes
and we've successfully incorporated all
of that into our care scan
essay and more importantly we also have
sample id tracking markers
to make sure that there is no cross
contamination or
sample mix up which is an advantage in a
large operations that people are pushing
through 96 samples at a time
so in conclusion kerascan essay
it's a high-throughput cost-effective
pan-ethnic target a panel combining smv
and cmv
determination with easy data reporting
it has the most comprehensive cmv care
screening solution
for challenging diseases such as sma dmd
and thalassemias it also has over 6 000
variants
that you can tailor and select uh
the content that you want to report out
and it has a great software to go with
it
so to learn more you can go to
thermofisher.com forward slash
carry scan
duran bahar the ceo of identifying
israel is a customer
of care scan and he couldn't be happier
after using it this is his statement
it's an
astonishment astonishing achievement to
have a single assay with the ability to
screen for thalassemia
spinal muscular atrophy duchenne
muscular dystrophy
cystic fibrosis general
hundreds of additional genetic
conditions and this ability is basically
a part of the promise and fulfillment of
the genomic revolution
to a better health and better future
now i'm going to switch here and talk
about the sequencing part
of our expanded carrier screening
research solution
called the kerasic kit this is a
complete end-to-end
ngs solution for ecs research
it's starting from genetic genomic dna
extracted from blood or saliva
and it has the ability to maximize
couples detection with full coding
sequences and cmv analysis
it consolidate tests for difficult to
sequence gene
just like carrier scan for example like
smn1 here for sma
it has the flexibility of multiplexing
either 4
or 16 samples per run and the simplicity
of adoption with customizable reporting
software
is incredible
so what you're seeing here is an ion tar
and ecs
kerosene ecs kit the partial gene list
here
what you're seeing in the middle column
of the target clinvar smb
indels with the sc those are actually
special case genes with dedicated
algorithm support
and the cmv column has a yes plus means
that we actually put in
dedicated care to carefully design
the snips around it to get a better
sense to get a better detection of these
genes
and these are just partial the list of
the genes that we have
what it comes out to be it's a two pull
ampliseq panels
we went through four design iterations
and tested with over 450
true positive research sample plus 68
synthetic variants
it's a full coding region of 420 genes
including 25 base fair flanking
intron exon boundaries and that ends up
with over 28
000 carriers smvs and indels from
clinvar
and as i was just mentioning out of the
420 genes
over 30 of them has focused cmvs with
extra amplicon designs
to be able to detect the difficult
detect genes that
was typically been shown very hard
to achieve proper sequencing detections
in all the homebrew assays
such as alpha and beta thalassemia dmd
goshare disease and sma
so kerostatis as i was just mentioning
genes like smn1s have high degree of
homologies
and paralogs gba has pseudogenes
and hba you know has pseudogenes within
the locus
so what we did was that krc uses a
combination
of sequence read that based copy number
analysis
and smv genotyping plus specialized
algorithm to call variants in three
classes of these special genes
for smn1 we target a copy number and smb
genotyping analysis
are used to determine the copy number of
exon 7
with special analysis calling functional
copy number
for hba it's a small gene distinct only
in exon 3.
so we actually use special algorithm
analysis to resolve copy number across
this homologous region
and then for gba and sip 21 2a
with sequence homology we basically use
primary
analysis considered gene copy number and
possible gene conversion event
as mutation detection mechanism
so what you're seeing here is
effectively the data analysis
variant for the care screening or the
keroseq approach
so on the left is the torrent suite
software that you use to plan
monitor and track your run and then iron
reporter is where
the bulk of the analysis happens where
the calling of
smv intel cmvs and gene conversion
happens
behind the scene and then on the right
it's the carrier reporter software
that automates the varying
classifications for care analysis and
reporting
for individuals and couples and this is
where
most of the lab people will spend most
of the time looking at
the variants at the end of the day
so the benefit here is that keroseq
has a full coding coverage of 420 genes
with analysis of smv intels and cmbs
and the outcomes that improve the
detections of couples who are at risk of
passing down serious conditions
and the benefit is that at risk couple
can pursue alternative actions
such as prenatal diagnosis or ivf
for the difficult to detect targets due
to homology such as sm1
and hba in a single ngs essay
we you know tremendously proud that we
have actually consolidated all these
standalone tests for technically
challenging
and improved lab efficiencies in terms
of time and expense for ecs
and we optimize essay kits and software
which would then streamline
implementation and help ensure reliable
and consistent results which then now
most of the labs can now pick up ecs and
you can learn more at thermofisher.com
careseek i like to continue on with our
discussion into pre-implantation genetic
testing
in the reproductive life cycle
why do we need to perform a
pre-implantation genetic testing
for aneuploidy now the benefit from this
graph
should be considered self-evidence but
let me just walk it through for you
on the top blue line the prevalence of
aneuploidy in human blastolysis obtained
in vitro
is between 30 to 85 if you look at the
graph
at the age of 30 you have an employee
rate of 30 percent
but when you reach the age of 44 to 45
the aneuploidy rate actually goes up to
85 degrees
on the middle green line you have the
risk of spontaneous miscarriage
that happens at 10 around the age of 30
all the way to 65 at the age of 44 to 45
and the risk of aneuploidy in human
fetus in prenatal diagnosis
is between 0.2 at age 30
to 3 percent at age 44 to 45.
so as women ages it's important to be
able to detect
endoploidy embryos to make sure that you
are
prioritizing healthier embryos or
transfer
so what do we provide we provide iron
reproceed
pgs kit which is a two to three
hour hand time product from cell to data
for 16 to 96 samples
you can see here they're divided into
three major blocks of the workflow
first on the ion single seek library
this is where
you extract the genomic dna
pre-amplified
amplify and purify the samples
and this is where the bulk of the
hands-on time is
anywhere from 75 minutes or 16 samples
to 150 minutes or 96 samples
when you get to the middle part of
templating using ion
chef the hands-on time drops down to 15
minutes and the pipetting and the chip
loading
all happens automatically within the
iron chef machine
and then when you get on to the
sequencing part of it again the hands-on
time is also only 15 minutes
where you only load the reagent into the
ion gene studio s5 systems
and you transfer the chip from the ion
chef
to the ion gene studio sequencing to
start sequencing there
so the ion represents pgs kit for
the gene studio system is for routine
detection a whole chromosome analogy and
chromosome
copy number event it's scalable
for 16 24 or 96 samples
which gives you lower cost per sample
and it helps you combat price erosion
it has simplified instrumentation that
helps you
make the easy to use and the ability to
process more sample
and therefore scale your lab into
increased sample volume
and help reduce demands on your
laboratory staff
as a 10 to 13 hour turnaround time
and improve data visualization and
detection for mercedes-ism
which then gives you the confidence in
interpretation of the results
and therefore you can also return
results in a time-bound manner
more importantly improve prioritizations
of the samples
you can learn more about this product at
thermofisher.com
i am represent
i would like to bring your attention to
dr collin lee from alpha fertility in
malaysia
who is extremely happy after using the
products as you can see in the middle
here
we've been using ion tar and ngs now for
about three years
the outcome is clear we don't have many
ambiguous or questionable results
and the scalability of the system is
good and as our experience with the
system increases
so does our confidence in results we
obtain
with the volume that we're expecting to
run before we bought the system
has been far exceeded because now
they're very confident and they can run
it very easily
the next one is an even more incredible
story that
really i think is important to highlight
dr louise alkaraz from our spanish
install base gone one step beyond
and provided further innovation to
combine
pgta and pgtm which is for monogenic
disorder
detection using the single biopsy
materials uh for both using the mpc
technology and the repository technology
here
so he was able to just take one biopsy
divided material into two
one run for the aneuploidy detection the
other one run for the monogenic disorder
detection
and you can see and find out more about
the product at www.pgd.seek.com
with that i'd like to then further bring
you into the next phase of the life
cycle
which is in the invasive prenatal and
the product of conception testing phase
so why perform invasive prenatal or
product for conception testing invasive
prenatal testing according to a
[ __ ] committee opinion from december
2016
is recommended for a mother with a fetus
that has one or more structural
abnormalities identify on an
ultrasonographic
examination and who is also undergoing
invasive prenatal
this is also recommended as a follow-up
test for any positive results on
screening tests
product of conception on the other hand
as we see
in pcrs march 2017 publication
is that majority of the spontaneous
miscarriage are sporadic
and caused by chromosome abnormalities
so couples with recurrent pregnancy loss
often undergo cytogenetic evolution
evaluation
of the product of conception to better
understand etiology
and this information then is important
to
use as a prevention for future pregnancy
complications
or miscarriages
how has it been done then for prenatal
testing
invested prenatal testing or product
with conception
typically it was done as in the left
hand corner called the kero typing
kero typing is a technology that's been
around for a while
but it's a lower diagnostic yield
technology
where only about three percent of the
cases of diagnosis made
and has a minimum deletion detectable of
5 megabases
or larger so anything smaller becomes
much harder to detect
actually what's more important difficult
to this technology is the next two major
points
one is the slower time to results
because if you are
collecting cells from amniotic fluid
there is not enough
material to detect you actually have to
grow them in cell culture
to get more samples more cells in order
to get the results and that cell culture
length increases the sample to result
time from 7 to 14 days
now the next part is the error prone
workflow analysis
this is actually quite a difficult
technology to scale
and you need specially trained
individuals and the interpretation is
very subjective
let's just take a look at the graphics
at the left hand corner
box there and the lower left you see six
different
chromosomes they are laid out but it's
actually the same
chromosome displayed six times they look
completely different and without a train
eye
you couldn't tell one from the other so
that's where the subjectivities
and the specialty needs of a trained
individual comes in
and it's not scalable because each
person can only do
so many at a time so what do we provide
in
um to solve these challenges then is the
cytoscan cytogenetic suite it's a
microarray based
detection technology it has a much
higher detection rate
of over three to fifteen percent
increases in discovery yields
it has a higher resolution that can
detect smaller chromosome aberrations
such as micro donations
or duplication snips in the technology
allows for detections of loss of
heterozygosity
loh or aoh triploidy
and maternal cell contamination
because it doesn't require cell culture
that enough dna just to use on its own
you can then get samples to result in
just three to five days
so it's much faster and because the
analysis
is done automatically using a software
now
you actually avoid the subjectivity
and the difficulty scale and the
trainability of the person
so we make it much easier to use you can
learn more at thermofisher.com for slash
pre-dash postnatal
so what does the suite include
on the left here you see that the suite
actually includes
the cytogenetic microarray called the
cytosken chip you have the kits reagent
you have the systems which is the gene
chip scanner 3000 series
and more importantly the chromosome
analysis suites software
it's a software that's designed by
cytogeneticists
for cytogeneticists so we know exactly
what's required for the cytogeneticists
to do their work
and therefore the software fulfills all
of that
so how do we cover that cytogenetic
suite is actually a genome-wide even
coverage of snips and cmd probe
it's a future-proof content because it's
already genome-wide
it removes any repeated validation
required
as new content comes online it's also an
acmg recommended first-line genetic test
platform
easy to use workflow and easy to use
analysis software
designed for by cytogenetics's four
cytogeneticists as i mentioned just now
the other component of the cytogenetic
suite is a different chip type
called the cytoscan exon array this is
focusing on comprehensive whole exome
coverage of cmd
and snip probes its proven ability to
detect
single exon deletion duplication missed
by whole exome sequencing
which we have a lot of customers who
have done that and and shown that
there are just cases where the
technology aren't
uh capable to go down to
it also has the same easy workflow as
statoscan cytogenetic suite therefore by
running both
you don't need to add another full-time
equivalent
to run that and the software is further
optimized to specific highlight claim
bar to your gene list
to help for prioritization of the
analysis
you can find more at thermofisher.com
forward slash setter scan
again i want to highlight some of our
customers testimonial of how they love
this cytoscan product this is dr
charlotte anderson
from odense university in denmark she
works with product of conception
materials
and at every miscarriage the dna is
usually
very degraded by the time they get the
samples however
because the system is so robust they are
still able to get results
and means a lot to the parents if they
need to answer
what causes the miscarriage the other
feature
she really likes about satoshi cytoscan
is the product
where the chairs the analysis software
have both
a cmv track and a snip track
now if a deletion in the copy number
variation track was detected
it can independently confirm in the snip
track
and therefore she doesn't need to go on
to another technology
to use for verification so that's a
beautiful
added benefit to the cytoscan product
to the cytogenetic community
now as i mentioned before cytoscan is
or chromosomal microarray is a
recommended first line for prenatal
testing
as we discussed just now at the acog
december
committee opinion here but dr webner
in 2012 also mentioned that chromosomal
microarray contained snips
allows for even greater discovery yield
as it can detect abnormality
such as uniparental disomi upd which is
very important
that you cannot see on other other
technologies
you can also see trig priority in cma
maternal cell contamination
and mosaicism and you know looking at
over 16
000 meta-analysis samples we show that
cma additionally detects the significant
aberrations
in 6.9 cases of ultrasound at melody
or through n 2.3 of all other
indications
so that's a huge benefit to add
i'm going to switch here a little bit to
go to the newborn now
after the prenatal and the newborn
screening research world
we are driven by two major diseases
first one is severe combined
immunodeficiency or skid
now skid is a severe genetic disorder
characterized by a lack of cellular and
chamorro immunity
this incidence is about one in forty
thousand to seventy five thousand life
birth
and it vary by genetic basis however
it's a hundred percent fatal unless it's
treated early
so there's no question about that it's
important to detect skid because it's
100
fatal children with skin should not
receive life vaccine
because actually that's what causes the
immune trigger response
over 90 of the survival of the early
hematopoietic stem cells transplantation
will be able to solve this problem
so the test here is based on measurement
of the episode dna product resulting
from immune
cell development or for the t cells
which is
track t cell receptor excision circle
and crack capital leading recombination
excision circle
the other condition is actually spinal
muscular atrophy
and we talked about this at the care
screening stage
um just now now sma is a degeneration of
motor neuron in
spinal cord and brain tissue and
progressive neural
muscular weakness it's the second most
common
fatal autosomal recessive disorder it
has a much higher carrier frequency of 1
in 50
to 60 and the incidence rate of 1 in 6
000 to 10
000 birth now what we are trying to
detect here is the deletions of both
copies of the sm1 gene
so the homozygous deletion here
so what is our motivation to develop
this essay then
the motivation is that in 2018 sma was
actually added to the recommended
uniform screening panel
or roughs in addition to skid
we also know that real-time pcr is
already established
in many of the labs researching in skid
because
you know our quad studio is the gold
standard of qpcr systems in the
scientific community
because we have two different block
types of 96 and 384
is actually a scalable throughput for
the reaction protocol
so for a medium throughput lab or high
throughput lab we have two different
block types to
help get through the throughput quickly
and we've been in the industry leader in
multiplexing of qpcr essays
therefore multiplexing essays to analyze
more than one condition
will minimize additional labor or
material costs
so what do we end up with we end up with
a techman-based
skit sma plus essay where you can go
from blood punch
to results with less than 20 minutes of
hands-on time
and only four reagent dispensing steps
and those are the four
to wash to lyse to essay and to run
wash we directly punch the blood card
into the tube with the wells and wash
them directly in there
and then we just then add lysis buffer
to it to lyse the cell and get the dna
out
the third dispensing is by adding the
master mix
of the apply biosystems tegmen skid and
sma plus sa into the well
and then we put it into our quant studio
system
and using our fast cycling protocol
we're able to get the results out
very very quickly
this is an example of an results that
you get
for the sm1 deletion here what you're
seeing here is that in the blue area the
sample
with homozygous deletion you see no
amplification
the black lines are the rnsp which is
your internal control to tell you that
your sample actually amplify and there's
dna in there
so it's a very clear yes no answer in
terms of
smn homozygous deletion there
this is a plot to clearly identify skit
samples what you see on top is the
normal samples
at the bottom are the skid samples and
what you're seeing again you have
black rna sp as a control and then
your blue and green of the track and
crack
essays falling off without amplification
on the lower box so it clearly
clearly tells you that the samples did
not have track or crack
essays dna but you have smn
which is a great another internal
control to confirm the same samples
there so in conclusion
the tankman assay for the newborn
screening has
robust quality it's optimized for high
specificity and detections of both
smn and skid it's simple
there's no dna extraction resulting in
less hands-on time and lower cost
and with minimal liquid dispensing the
asset can be easily be automated
the speed is fast because we have pros
we can process more samples
in less than 20 minutes or so hands on
time and finally without
additional instrumentation needs and
us being the world leaders in qpcr
reagents and consumables
we can provide the greatest cost savings
to run
this newborn screening for the genetic
testing of skid and sma essays
finally i want to bring you back to the
last part that we see in the reflective
life cycle which is in the pulse
native screen why do we need to do
postnatal screening
this is a data published in 2014 to 2016
there was a marxist increase in
children diagnosed with ddid or asd
dd is developmental delay id is
intellectual disability and asd is
autism spectrum disorder and you can see
that the graph
on the right just increases over year
over year from 2014 to 2016.
in the case of children with autism
spectrum disorder
there are research studies shown that
the earlier you detect
and diagnose a kid the sooner
you can bring out the maximum capacity
of this child
versus those who are diagnosed after the
age of four
because the later they are diagnosed it
it becomes harder
to bring them out out to become to have
their full potential here
so how is it being done today in the
postnatal cytogenetic testing world
if you are a dd or id suspicious
you go through cytoscan as the first
tier test
on top here and then you go through next
generation sequencing
if there's only one hit you add cytoscan
excellent sweep to it to uncover the
second hit
it's a long drawn out journey what we're
trying to propose is that
instead of going through ngs and exon
after cytoscan suite
you go and combine ngs and exxon suite
together
and we have examples from children's
hospital of los angeles
where they actually speed up the
detection and finding
much less questionable genes to go
investigate
much quicker now on the bottom if you
have
other suspected genetic disorders
instead of going through the same
process of going through ngs or saying
or sequencing
finding one hit and then add cytoskin
exon sweet
you we are encouraging you to
incorporate ngs and cytoscan exon suites
together to speed up the testing journey
here
so what do we offer we actually offer
the same product as prenatal
using the cytoskene cytogenetic suite
and the cytoskin exon suite
together for the postnatal testing again
let me just
reiterate saudi scan cytogenetic suite
it's a genome-wide
even coverage of snips and cmb probes it
has future-proof content
and removing repeated validation as new
content comes along
it's hcmg recommended first-line genetic
test platform
easy to use workflow and analysis
and then with the exon it complements
really well
cytoscan cytogenetic suites and next
generation sequencing
because its whole exome coverage of cmb
and snip probes
and it has the proven ability to detect
single exon deletions and duplications
missed by holoxime sequencing it helps
finding second hit
and it's the same easy workflow as
cytoscan cytogenetic
suite this one i point you specifically
to thermofisher.com for slash
set of scan exxon to learn more about it
so dr christina telling me from
karolinska institute in sweden
had done this research a few years ago
and what she really
uh she actually does both cma and whole
exome sequencing using our ion tar
technology as well
and she finds that you know both cma and
whole exome sequencing are valuable
in establishing molecular diagnostics in
asd and with microarray they can
actually get to results
fast and uncovering what's clinically
significant
and the speed is important because it
helps them plan the next steps in their
studies
so finally i want to bring you to this
case example
of waterberg syndrome here this is a
case
where the mother has waterberg 2
syndrome
and the father has wardenburg syndrome
and a family history of voldemort
syndrome
they unfortunately have a stillborn
fetus
at 32 weeks old so they really want to
find out what causes
distilled birth so they ran it on
saturday scan
hd platform here in the u.s they look
at a large they found enlarged deletions
across a sox-10 gene
but then when they want to find the
second reason behind it
um they won't be able to find it right
sox10 is
um known to be a wattenberg causing gene
so they ran a waterberg syndrome panel
they found nothing
they ran a whole exome sequencing across
pax 3
you know all the genes that are listed
on the right hand corner
column they couldn't find anything
either so they ended up running cytoskin
exon and what they found was that it's
actually a nested homozygous
lesion within the sox10 genes so the
resolution
of the exon platform was able to give
such high
resolution that it enables them to find
this
nested homozygous deletion that we're
not able to find
with whole exome sequencing or other
panel runs that they've done
so it's a great testament to how the
technology helps
move the research forward and find
answers to the family who are looking
for an
answer
so i just want to wrap it up with the
cytoscan portfolio of some of the
histories that we have cytoskene
cytogenetics suite has
been around since 2011. we've sold in 36
countries around the world
over 300 customers happy customers who
are using it
more importantly over 2600 publications
cited so far
if you look at the bar graphs at the
bottom those are
individual year count they're not
cumulative so
it's amazing to see that a product that
is so mature continues to generate so
many publications
year over year and increasing there and
the milestone we achieved
is that in 2014 we have received fda
cleared for satisfaction exxon dx
dx sa sorry and 2015
we've sold over half a million units of
cytosken hd
and then in 2018 we have launched
cytoscan exon suite
so that's a you know a great achievement
here
finally i want to wrap this up with what
i said on the third pillar
of us being a trusted partner is
providing world-class support
now all of this great product is not
sufficient
if we don't have a right support
structure in place
so i'm very happy to tell you that we
have now
a follow the sun support model where
any time you reach a tech support either
through phone or through email
your case will be carried through until
it's fully resolved
we know that in various types of labs
especially in the ivf testing labs
time is as an essence and it's you know
a lot of some of people
really need a 13 or 14 or 24 hour
turnaround
so having this type of follow the sun
support model
really supports the important work that
our customers are doing on a day-to-day
basis
so again i want to wrap it up hopefully
i have told you
about how we want to be your trusted
partners
by offering innovative genetic solutions
that enable
you our customers to make future
generations healthier
by advancing your business growth with
menu expansion as i showed just now
from carer screening to
pre-pre-implantation genetic testings
to prenatal to newborn screening and to
postnatal
and finally by providing reproductive
health customers like you
with our world-class support we
hopefully will be
able to earn your trust to your trusted
partners
just to remind you again our lovely
reproductive health life cycles
of the five applications areas were
actively
involved in with that thank you very
much
and we will be happy to take any
questions you may have